Okay, guys, we got a customer. It's that
um person who follows the rabbis. Okay,
here you go.
>> Hello.
>> Yes, sir. So, I So, I gather you're an
Orthodox Jew who follows these rabbis.
>> I'm I'm not I'm a secular Jew.
>> Okay. So, as a secular Jew, why do you
care about the Tanakh?
>> You still care about the Tanakh?
>> Okay. Read Exodus 15:3 for me. Exodus
15:3. Open up Exodus 15:3. Don't talk
over me. Give me Open up your book.
>> Well, what kind of
>> Do you want me to hang up on you? Okay,
I'm going to hang up on you. I'm
answering your question.
>> I'll go to the Exodus.
>> Totally. I'm answering your question.
Breathe. Calm down. I want to make you
infamous. Go to Exodus 15:3. Read to me
what it says in Hebrew.
>> Exodus
>> 15:3.
>> Read for me what it says in Hebrew.
The Lord is a warrior.
The Lord is his name.
>> No, that's not what the Hebrew says.
Give me the Hebrew.
>> The Hebrew? No, I can't I can't speak
Hebrew.
>> Okay, wait. You're a secular Jew who
can't speak Hebrew. Then how am I going
to have this conversation with you?
Because it doesn't say war.
>> No. No. Every Jewish person can speak
Hebrew, man.
>> Read Genesis 18.
>> What's wrong with Muslims?
>> What's wrong with Muslims? No, nothing
wrong with Muslims. It's those who are
jihadis like you
>> and no idol worshippers. You want to bet
they lick the black stone like the pagan
that you are. So licking a black stone,
kissing the black stone is not idolatry.
>> No, it's not.
>> Read Leviticus 26:1. Read Leviticus
26:1. You're a liar. You don't know your
Bible because you're not a secular Jew.
Read Leviticus 26:1.
>> Well, why are we jumping from verses to
vers?
>> Read Leviticus 26:1. Because you jumped,
you coward. You said they're not
idoltors. Read Leviticus 26:1. So I can
show you from your Bible.
I want to hang up on you if you don't
turn. Leviticus 26:1.
>> That's what I'm reading right now.
>> Read it.
>> Y shall make for yourself no idols and
erect no g images, builders, and you
shall not place thicker stones in your
land.
>> You're not going to do what with stones?
>> But I'm not going to say that that
>> I didn't ask what you said. What did the
verse say? You're not going to do what
with stones?
>> In your land.
>> What kind of stones?
sacred stones.
>> Okay. Now, at the time of Moses, if an
Israelite was found kissing a black
stone and smothering it and weeping over
it, what would Moses have done to him?
>> It doesn't matter because the Jew
>> Answer the question again. What would
Moses have done to him?
>> Say it again.
>> Thank you for admitting that Moses would
have Muhammad like the demon that he is
because that's what Muhammad did. Thank
you.
>> The stone.
>> Let's repeat it again. Muhammad made it
part of the Sunnah to kiss the black
stone and and touch it and weep on it.
And I asked you, what would Moses have
done to an Israelite who kissed a black
stone? He would have Thank you. You're
on record, Tully, for saying Moses would
have Muhammad as a son of an idoltor.
Thank you.
>> I don't think they worshiped the stones
at all. I didn't ask you worship. I
said, "What would Moses have done if he
caught an Israelite kissing a black
stone?" See, you're twisting my words.
>> Moses know that he's not worshiping the
stone. You wouldn't kill.
>> Where does the Bible say that you can
kiss a stone if it's not for worship?
Why are you kissing the stone?
>> What significance does the stone have?
Why are you kissing it?
>> I'm not sure with the Muslims, but
>> Okay. You're not sure? All right. Now,
let's go back to Genesis 18. Let's go
back to the point of God appearing as a
man and being a man. Go to Genesis 18.
>> I know this verse. You always refer to
this verse.
>> Okay. If you know it, tell me who is the
man that appeared to Abraham. Let's see
how much you know it.
>> That's a that's an angel.
>> Show me where it says it's an angel.
Show me that in Genesis 18. It says it's
Hashem, Jehovah.
>> It doesn't say in this translation.
>> It it doesn't say in any translation. Go
get Kabad. Open up kabad.org.
The text says it's Hashem, it's Jehovah
that appeared as a man and ate food with
two other angels.
Read Genesis 18 verses 1 to 14.
>> All right, I'll catch the help.
>> Okay, go ahead. Read it.
>> I was referring to Micah. That's the
verse I was
>> That's okay. We'll get to Micah and I'm
going to bury you in Micah in a minute
because I'm going to show you from Kabad
that's about Messiah. Your own
kabad.org. Razi said Micah 52 is about
King Messiah. Do you agree with Raz?
Yes. Okay. Go to kabad.org.
>> Go to kabad.org. Go to micica 52. Read
to me. Rashi says this is who. Read it
because I have in front of me.
Someone let Rashi bury you and prove my
point. It's about Msiah.
Rashi never mentioned that.
>> Open Micah 5:2. I don't care for your
opinion. Read to me what Rashi said. Who
is this ruler from Bethlehem?
This is your funeral service unless you
repent.
Open it up because I have it right here.
You want me to read it for you?
>> Yes, please.
>> Okay. Here you go. I'm gonna give you
the link. Hold on so you don't think I'm
making it up. Kabad.org. This is
rabbitic Jewish website with their own
English translation. Let me get you the
link for yourself.
Worst mistake you could have done to try
to challenge Micah 52 because I'm gonna
let Rashi prove my case and refute you.
Here it is. Let me just get it. It's not
opening up. One second. Micah. All
right. Hold on. Five. Here you go.
Uhhuh. Oppa.
Okay. Hold on. Show. Here you go. I'm
going to give it to you and you're going
to read it for me. All right.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Here you go. Here you go. There
you go. Oh, here you go in the comment
section right here, chat. Here it is.
Let me accept. Click on it. And here I'm
going to give it to Aladi to share it.
Alth
>> Okay. Well, click on it. Open. I'll read
it for you. And you Bethlehem
Ephraatha
and [clears throat] this is Rash now.
Once David anim emanated as it is stated
the son of your bondman bondsman Jesse
the Bethleamite and Bethlehem is called
Ephrath as it is said Genesis 48:7 on
the road to Ephrath that is Bethlehem.
Wait be patient let me read it so you
can hear.
>> You should have been the lowest of the
clans of Judah. You should have been the
lowest of the clans of Judah because of
the stigma of Ruth the Moabitis in you.
from you shall emerge for me the
Messiah, son of David.
And so scripture says Psalm 18:22, the
stone the builders had rejected became a
cornerstone. So Rashi, you're not a
Christian. Who is this? Mashiach Ben
Davidid, Messiah, son of David. Do you
agree with Rashi?
>> But that's not referring to Jesus.
>> Do I don't care if it's Jesus. Do you
agree it's Messiah? Yes. It's referring
to the to the son of David.
>> It's not just son of David. Messiah, son
of David, right?
>> Yes.
>> So whether you accept Jesus or not, the
fact that Jesus is born in Bethlehem at
least shows that that's consistent with
the prophecy because Rashi says the
prophecy is Messiah who come from
Bethlehem.
>> The the Messiah he's talking about is
not Jesus.
>> That's not what I said. Let me repeat. I
know it's hard because you got
embarrassed. You humiliate yourself.
It's okay. I'll be gentle in your
destruction.
The fact that Micah 5:2 is about Messiah
>> shows that at least Jesus being born in
Bethlehem
meets at least that criteria to be
Messiah whether you accept him or not
because your argument was that Micah 52
is not just not about Jesus. It's not
about Messiah.
>> I didn't say as long.
>> Okay. So you agree it's about Messiah,
right?
>> Yes, I agree. So then if Jesus is born
in Bethlehem, does that at least show
that part of the requirement being
Messiah is fulfilled? I'm not saying
that he is, but at least that part of
the criteria.
>> But it it doesn't matter. I guess
there's a lot of
>> You didn't answer my question. We'll get
to the other criteria which will all
backfire against you. Let me try it
again.
The fact that Jesus was born in
Bethlehem, does that at least show that
part of the criteria that Messiah comes
from Bethlehem has been met in Jesus? I
didn't say all of it. I said that
specific part.
>> I wouldn't say it's referring to Jesus.
>> See, again, that's not what I asked. Do
I need to ask it a fifth time, friend?
>> Okay, let let me let me
>> Okay, hold on. You didn't answer the
question. Let me answer the fifth time.
The fact that Jesus was born in
Bethlehem, does that at least show that
Jesus meets that part of the criteria
that Messiah come from Bethlehem? At
least that part of the criteria he
meets. I didn't say it's about Jesus.
Did Jesus meet at least that part of the
criteria?
>> Yeah, that's just one, isn't it?
>> Okay, good. At least we're now we're
getting somewhere. Now you're being
honest. Okay. Yeah. If Jesus born in
Bethlehem, then he meets that part of
the criteria. Okay. So, what was your
objection against Jesus being
fulfillment of Micah 5:2?
>> Because it wasn't referring to to Jesus.
>> How do you know if he's born in
Bethlehem where Messiah would be born?
>> That's that's what I was saying. Like
there's a lot of anointed people that
was born in in in
>> Name me one that claimed to be Messiah
that came out of Bethlehem. Give me one
name.
>> I can't give you any names.
>> Okay. So, don't tell me there was a lot
of anointed people. You have none to
show me who claimed to be Messiah that
came out of
>> according to Josephus, there was a lot
of Messiah.
>> Show me where Josephus says any of them
were born of Bethlehem.
>> I'm not talking about Bethlehem, but
around the
>> See, again, you're attacking straw man.
Let me repeat it again. We're talking
about the prophecy of Bethlehem. You
said there were a lot of anointed people
that came out of it. No, you cannot show
me any other so-called messianic
claimment that came out of Bethlehem
with the exception of Jesus. Not even
Josephus helps your case. And why are
you appealing to Josephus when the Jews
reject him?
>> Like he's still he's straight up. He
can't
>> You sure? Because if you're going to go
with Josephus, he mentions Jesus, the
so-called Christ, and mention James.
>> There's no Jesus in there, man. Come on
now,
>> friend. He mentions James, the brother
of Jesus, so-called Christ, and Jesus,
the so-called Christ, and John the
Baptist. Prove those are not genuine
statements from Josephus. Prove it.
Those those are are Catholic assertions.
>> Prove it because the only copies you
have of Josephus Okay, one more time.
>> Tully, listen. The only copies you have
of Josephus are from the Christians. So,
prove their interpolations.
>> No. From the Christians.
>> You have no copy of Josephus that's not
written by Christians. All your copies
are after Christianity during the
medieval period produced by Christians
because Jews did not copy Josephus. This
why I asked you why are you quoting him?
Because the Jews considered him a
traitor. So you are ignorant who think
you know your stuff.
>> Look look he is a traitor but he can't
deny that.
>> Okay then prove to me those are
interpolations.
>> I can't prove it to you. I don't have
>> so stop making assumptions and only
embarrass yourself. What's your next
argument?
>> All the scholars agreed that that's a
Catholic assertion.
>> No you're lying. I will quote to you
scholars who are liberal like John
Dominic Croan that say no this is
generally Joseph I have him quoted in my
article why are you lying
>> what about
her what did he say her so let's forget
about John do crissan and others and you
go with one isolated opinion barer and
show me what barer said about it give me
the page number in the book
>> he said I was a Catholic assertion
>> show me give me the page number and the
book I can't give you the book. It was
It was on
>> What's your next objection?
>> My next objection is
if Jesus was the Messiah, why he didn't
fulfill all the the the messianic
prophecies?
>> Prove to me he didn't.
>> No, that's a question for you to ask.
>> No, we're telling you he did. Prove to
me he didn't. What prophecy that you
think he didn't fulfill?
>> He didn't. That the the opposite.
>> Give me one.
>> The opposite happened.
Which one you want me want want me to
>> which part of one wasn't clear?
Give me one that you think is about
Messiah that he didn't fulfill.
>> The Jews went into exile when during his
time.
>> You mean hold on. You mean when the Jews
were still spread out all over the
world, diaspora Jews, and not all of
them had returned to the land and the
land wasn't in their power and
jurisdiction. That's a prophecy. And
where does it say? Give me the verse
that connects it with the coming
Messiah. Give me the verse. You just
gave me an assumption. What verse are
you quoting? Give it to me.
>> The verse that
>> Give it to me.
>> What verse you want? Sorry.
>> The one you just mentioned. For the love
of your Allah. Give it to me.
>> I'm not a Muslim man.
>> It doesn't matter. You're worse than a
Muslim. At least they believe Jesus is
the Messiah. By the way, do you agree
with the Muslims? Do you agree with the
Muslims that Jesus is the Messiah?
>> That's That's their opinion.
>> I didn't ask you that. Do you agree with
them that Jesus is the Messiah?
>> No, I don't.
>> Do you agree with them that the Messiah
Jesus born of a virgin?
>> No, I don't.
>> Do you agree that the Messiah, Jesus,
prophesied the coming of Muhammad?
>> Jesus prophesied Muhammad.
>> Yeah. They say in the Quran that the
Messiah, Jesus, son of Mary, prophesied
Ahmed, whom they say is Muhammad.
>> And I don't agree with that.
>> Okay. Now, do you agree if Messiah shows
up if he shows up? Do I listen? I want I
want because you Jews and Muslims will
gang up together attack Jesus when you
are dishonest because you don't believe
the other is genuine because I'm going
to use you to prove my point. If Messiah
shows up if Messiah shows up.
>> Yep.
>> Will there be a prophet that comes after
him who will be an Arab?
>> No.
>> Say it again. I want everyone music to
my ear. Say it again.
>> No. The prophet starts with um Malaki.
>> Okay. So, no. No. I didn't ask you that.
I said if Messiah shows up, if he shows
up, will there then there then be a
prophet that comes after him who's an
Arab? If Messiah shows up?
>> No.
>> Okay. Now, the Muslims say Jesus is the
Messiah. Now, just for argument sake,
I'm not saying you believe Jesus is the
Messiah. If Jesus is the Messiah, would
he, if he's the Messiah, prophesy the
coming of an Arab prophet?
>> I don't think so.
>> Thank you. Muslims, you hear that? This
Jew just buried you guys because of
Jesus Messiah. No one comes after Jesus
the Messiah who's an air prophet. Thank
you for helping me use you to destroy
Islam. But
>> Jesus isn't the Messiah.
>> That No, the Muslims say he is. They say
you're a liar. There he is.